so in keeping with my promise to elevate
black voices that deserve to be heard
and are completely ignored by everyone
else in the media we have a follow-up
tonight on a story we brought you back
in may the story of 22-year-old king
randall now king's group the extra boys
has empowered his community at risk
youth by not only giving them a safe
space a safe place but also through
education he's also not just teaching
out of a textbook king teaches his kids
everything from how to change a tire to
how to mow a lawn when we last spoke
with king
king was battling with his local school
board leadership who was doing
everything possible to keep him from
opening his own school people said it
was impossible for this 22 year old kid
to run a school but he's defined the
odds and is now set to open up his first
school next fall king randall is the
founder of the extra boys and he joins
me now
with an update
king always so proud of you brother um
how were you able to do this because
they were throwing everything at you
man uh lawrence i'll say this i believe
you know that anybody who says that
something can't be done doesn't know my
god
and i think that's extremely important
for us to know
we have to make sure that we are
creating competing machines for these
different progressive systems that are
plaguing and destroying our communities
our children are failing at reading our
children are failing at many different
things uh in our local hometown of
albany georgia but here we are trying to
help our young men and push them forward
by creating this program called the ex
for boys we read with them weekly this
is every week
we do workshops with them we teach them
firearms training we teach them how to
work on cars we teach them how to work
on houses they've done welding and many
different things just trying to give
them an idea of how to make it and how
to survive how to make it happen these
children just need to see possible and
so many of our children in the city of
albany don't get to see possible but
right now they're going to see a 22 year
old young man who's not too far off from
age
from any of the boys in the program
they're going to see me open up my own
school
in fall of 2022 and we're going to
flourish they told me that it was going
to be impossible to run our school on
private donors yet here our private
donors have shown up in 24 hours for us
to raise 50 000
for renovations on our new three
buildings that we purchased uh so here
we are defying the odds because they
don't know my god
so king i guess my big question it's
almost rhetorical why don't why don't we
hear more stories like you out there
because they exist
i try to cover them every week
i'll definitely say many of our favorite
uh favorite black leaders whom are
pushed in the media who have their fists
up etc
are more focused on you know the
different ideologies that are kind of
plaguing our communities i always say
you know people have accused me of
getting funding from the gop et cetera
i'm like actually i haven't gotten a
call from gop but your favorite black
voices are being paid by this same
system that you claim is oppressing you
but you get mad at me and call me a
sellout for not selling out to the
system um this is what we deal with i
remember uh one of the biggest catch
phrases for black lives matter was i
can't breathe we have so many young
black men in our cities that are saying
right now that they can't breathe yet
they're standing around they have so
much energy for young black men after
they're dead but we need to be fighting
for young black men before they die you
know
maybe the gop should call you may maybe
every conservative organization that is
focused on our outreach should reach out
to you uh you're teaching them stuff
that is gonna carry them a lifetime the
you're not just teaching them you're
making the next generation of men that
are going to take care of their families
that that when their wife can't do her
oil change they can change the tire do
the oil change all of that and it
shouldn't be just you know
peed on
right absolutely and you know i shun at
people who try to politicize my message
um i've had a lot of you know people um
even conservatives get upset with me
from maybe going to different spaces to
where maybe black people don't have the
best you know ideas or sayings about
white people or et cetera and i'm just
like no i have to go to these spaces to
give the message i have to go there and
tell them the truth about what's
actually going on in our communities
because the black voices that they're
putting out in front of us are not
telling us the truth about what's going
on in our communities we have to push
that forward so yes we're we're building
young men i'm trying to make it a unity
piece where we're unifying so many
different groups of people our following
is so diverse we have liberals we have
conservatives we have libertarians etc
who literally support our program
because of that one main message and if
i can get them all to see that you have
the same issue is not within your race
it's not within the parties it's within
your government and if we all unify on
one front and go confront our issues we
can make something happen and that
starts with our young men that's right
um you can't be 22 can't be 22
i encourage everyone to support you
and you know from all the brothers that
i hang with we say we appreciate you
young black men and we appreciate the
impact that you're making uh on young
black men's lives we thank you so much
and i think everybody should follow and
support you because i'm going to make my
contribution when i get off the air
tonight thank you so much king
thank you for having me lawrence hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else